MARY GROVE: So good
afternoon, everyone.
Are we having a
great day so far?
Wonderful.
Well, I am so honored to host a
discussion today with a leader
I very much admire,
someone who really
is a leader in both the
finance and tech worlds
and is able to brilliantly
bridge between the two.
As Karishma mentioned, Ruth is
Senior Vice President and Chief
Financial Officer of Alphabet,
and she joined the company
in May 2015.
Prior to that, Ruth was
Executive Vice President
and Chief Financial Officer of
Morgan Stanley, where she also
held a variety of
leadership roles
prior to joining the highest
ranks of the company.
Ruth has an amazing,
diverse set of interests.
She is the Vice Chair of
the Stanford University
Board of Trustees.
She is also on the
Board of Directors
of the Council for
Foreign Relations.
She holds an undergrad degree
from Stanford University, MBA
from the Wharton
School, and a master's
from the London
School of Economics.
So Ruth is someone who really
has been transformative in sort
of shaping the next
chapter of our company,
and we are so
honored to have her
here today to share some
personal insights with us as
well.
So welcome, Ruth.
RUTH PORAT: Thank you.
It's great to be
here with everyone.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MARY GROVE: So Ruth, you
joined Alphabet, then Google,
last May, and it's been quite
a ride the last 10 months.
Can you tell me about
your current focus
areas and sort of what are your
highest priorities right now?
RUTH PORAT: Well,
the biggest surprise
when I joined Google
at the time-- Alphabet
now-- is how early
stage Google really is.
And when you think about
all of the products
we have, just go through
them one after the other,
it's clear how
early stage we are,
which is extraordinary to say
with a company of our scale.
So you think about how many
people still are not online.
They're going to go online
with the mobile handset.
You think about how
we're using our phones.
You think about advertising
moving from offline to online,
and what that means
for YouTube, or you
think about companies
moving to the cloud.
And the fact that
we're really early
means that we have a
ton of opportunities.
And the biggest challenge last
year was the 2016 budgeting.
How do you prioritize?
How do I determine, working
with business leaders,
where to put funding,
how to allocate capital?
And it was a tough process,
a really productive process.
But it's also not a
once-and-done process.
So as we completed the
year, we set a number
of milestones,
business and technical,
for business leaders as we
think about how to fund.
And we're still working on that.
And I think it's
really a testament
to just how many extraordinary
opportunities are still
out there.
MARY GROVE: So much to
accomplish, come in,
wrap your head around it,
and then go immediately
into annual planning.
So well done.
So you were a seasoned
executive at Wall Street.
How has the transition
been to Silicon Valley?
And can you sort of
compare the culture
of Wall Street to
Silicon Valley?
RUTH PORAT: It's probably
more similar for me
than I think many would expect.
I grew up out here.
I went to high school just down
the street at Menlo-Atherton.
I went to Stanford.
As you said, I'm on
the Stanford board,
so I had been out here all
the time for the board.
And every time I came out here,
I left, I got back to New York,
and said, the optimism
in Silicon Valley
is extraordinary, and it's
what makes this country great.
And when I came
back out here, that
was the most
embracing part of it.
But I think the reason
it's not that different
in certain respects is what
kept me at Morgan Stanley
much longer than I anticipated--
I used to always tell
my family, I'm going to be at
Morgan Stanley for five years
and then I'm moving
back out here.
And after 28 years, they
thought I couldn't count.
But the reason I
stayed was I was
solving clients' problems,
working with the greatest
clients.
Got to work with
Google on the IPO.
But it was a constant
learning experience,
and there were new things
to address all the time.
New industries were created.
And it's that learning
element that I
find so invigorating
about being out here.
MARY GROVE: So 28 years.
That was a huge chapter.
Now it's been 10
months to look at.
What has been your proudest
accomplishment of the last 10
months since joining Alphabet?
RUTH PORAT: This may
sound like an odd one,
but I think culture is so
critical to the success
of any organization.
Culture defines the way people
act in ways that rules can't.
It's just the
unwritten, the ethics,
the creed that people follow.
And I feel very
much at home here.
I feel I've got an
extraordinary team.
And for me, just being able to
get in the slipstream is what
it feels like, is really
important to being
able to get things done.
MARY GROVE: So looking
across the Google universe,
then, what is a product area
or an emerging technology
that you're especially bullish
on, excited about, and why?
RUTH PORAT: It's a hard one
to answer, because as I said,
we're so early stage
across a number of areas.
I'm really excited about the way
the personal assistant machine
learning is affecting how we
use our phone, the ability
to predict what we need
and be so much more useful.
I love what's going on
with virtual reality.
I'm really excited about what
we're doing in education.
We are a leading player in
schools with our Chromebooks.
And more than that, we have
this virtual reality product
called Cardboard, which
hopefully all of you
have experienced.
And we can take
kids back in history
and around the globe with
something that's super simple.
You just slot your phone
in, and it's the ability
to provide anybody--
it's not just
for the few elite-- anybody can
go anywhere around the globe.
And the ability to tell kids,
you can be anything, you
can get anywhere.
I find that really exciting.
So it's not a very fair answer,
but it's an accurate answer.
We have a leader who's
focused on something
that's a priority for us,
the next billion users.
The ability to bring the next
four to five billion people out
of poverty by giving them
access to information.
All of these things
to me are what makes
it so exciting to be here.
MARY GROVE: It's so amazing
and refreshing for me
to hear you say that Google's
early stage in so many ways,
because I joined Google
in 2004, so 12 years ago,
and at the time we were
about 2,000 people.
Now, of course, we're
over 60,000 people.
But refreshing for
me and so many of us
to still remember that we
still are so early stage
in so many areas, and there's so
much opportunity still to come.
RUTH PORAT: Exactly.
MARY GROVE: So I want
to shift gears a bit
and talk about leadership,
and your perspective on that,
and lessons that we
can learn from you.
So what would you say
you look for most?
What core attributes,
when you build a team
and you hire leadership
into your team,
what do you look for?
RUTH PORAT: I look for
a number of things.
One, clearly passion
and excellence
in all that's being done.
I look for
intellectual curiosity,
because the one thing you know
is the world will constantly
change.
I want people who are learners.
I want people who always
start questions with, well,
what are we solving for?
Because you can solve
any problem if you stop
and actually ask, how do we
think about this differently?
I do like to have
a mix of people
for whom a role is
a massive stretch
goal, coupled with those where
they have pattern recognition.
That's a term I use a lot.
I think experience, and
therefore pattern recognition,
is really valuable.
And having the right
mix on your team is key,
and it underscores why the
experience everyone gets
in their first role or
second role is so key.
You get a lot of
great experiences
that then are relevant
in later life.
I look for pattern recognition
as well as battle scars.
And that's a term I ask
about in interviews.
And then finally,
I think one thing
that's absolutely critical for
a leadership team is diversity.
There's a lot of
research that says
that you have a better financial
outcome, a better business
outcome when you have a diverse
team, because people come
with different
perspectives, and so I think
all of those elements are
key to the way I think
about constructing the team.
MARY GROVE: The diversity
point is very well-taken.
I know that the
data does show us
that it really is better
for business, not just
the right thing to do.
And you've been
outspoken on this issue.
Have you seen progress in the
industry over the past year?
RUTH PORAT: A year is too
short a period of time.
It's a great question.
I think what I've
seen a change--
the change in the
last year is there
is more discussion
about the fact
that it's not just
the right thing to do,
but it's right for business.
And I think as we
collectively try and figure
out how best to draw
men into the discussion,
it's a really
valuable point, which
is, if you want to be
the strongest leader,
you need a diverse team.
You have to look at
the board of directors,
your senior leadership
team, each of your teams.
And so it's helpful as
we're trying to then come up
with what are the concrete
steps that we can collectively
take to make a difference?
MARY GROVE: Right.
How many women in
this room have started
a company, started
an organization,
started their own venture?
Great.
So what advice, Ruth, do you
have for young founders who
are just starting
out, especially when
thinking about
building diverse teams?
Often there's
discussion of, gosh,
do you have to make
trade-offs in order
to build a diverse team?
And I emphatically think
that's not the case.
But how do you advise
leaders to think
about building an
organization with that in mind
from the get go?
RUTH PORAT: I think there are
two parts to your question
which are really important.
I think the first one is, how do
you build a super successful--
how do you succeed?
If I start at kind
of the highest level
and then go to the next
part of your question,
which is diversity.
I think it is critical
that each of us,
whether founding a
company, in a company,
at every point in my career,
that we have sponsors.
We have people who
will take risk on us.
We will have people who are
in positions of authority
and can give us those
breakaway opportunities.
And in my career
I'm often asked,
how did I know when
to move around?
I didn't.
I had somebody who was in
a position of authority who
was willing to take
risk on me, who gave me
the opportunity,
who said, I'm going
to be your senior air cover.
One guy did that and
it was super valuable.
Another one said, you're
going to sink or swim,
and that's all
right because you're
going to learn, no
matter what happens.
And I'm there for you.
And so to me, the
starting point is,
make sure whether you're
starting a company
or in a company, that
you have people there
who have your back,
who have that pattern
recognition, that
experience, who are
taking a personal risk on you.
That is the single most
important thing I can say.
The first position I
had at Morgan Stanley,
I worked for a guy on a deal.
And I worked around
the clock and never
even went to internal meetings.
And about a month
or two into it,
I finally got to go
to an internal meeting
with the managing director.
And the managing director
looked at him and said,
is this the I that I
keep hearing about?
And it was my wake-up moment.
This guy had been taking
credit for my work.
And what it really
taught me at an early age
is, women in particular,
I think we have a tendency
to put our head down,
work really hard,
and expect good
things will happen.
And if you're working
for the wrong boss,
that's not going to happen.
If you don't have people out
there who have your back,
that's not going to happen.
So the most
important message is,
make sure you're working with
someone who has your back.
Make sure they're super
confident in themselves,
because if they're not, it's
going to be harder for them
to put themselves out there.
Most-- not most, all of
my sponsors have been men.
And the reason is,
as I was growing up
through the
organization, there just
weren't women in
senior positions.
And so your sponsors don't
need to look like you to still
be in a position to help you.
And so I think those
are critical elements.
And then your other point, which
is so important, diversity.
I agree with you.
It's not a trade-off.
We can look for the best
talent and round out our team.
And I think that notion that you
can have tunnel vision if you
don't have diversity
by gender, by race,
by socioeconomic background,
by sexual orientation--
there are lot of different
ways we can bring diversity
into your decision-making
team, and it's really important
to do that.
MARY GROVE: So to
your earlier point,
the first point about
sponsors-- and you and I
have spoken before about
how the process of getting
a sponsor, which is different
from a mentor-- both
are important-- is
somewhat organic.
You don't just walk
up to someone and say,
will you be my sponsor?
So I thought you've
had really great advice
about how to
advocate for yourself
and how to provide updates.
Can you elaborate a bit
on that for our audience?
RUTH PORAT: I will,
but I think you
made a really important point.
I think some people
struggle with,
can you just walk up
to somebody and say,
will you be my sponsor?
And the reason I
completely agree
with you is, your sponsor
is taking risk on you.
And so they need to
know who you are.
You need to have earned
the opportunity for them
to actually put
themselves in a position
where it could hurt
them personally
or professionally if
you drop the ball.
And so I completely
agree with you,
you got to earn that right.
I think there are a couple
of really important elements,
in particular, for women.
One is, too often, as I said, we
put our heads down, work hard,
and expect good things
will occur and be noticed.
Men do a much
better job providing
the head of a group,
the head of a business,
with updates about what
they're doing than do women.
And when I first was in a
position running a group,
it really struck
me how often I'd
get these really pithy, little
nice updates from the men.
I just did this deal,
just had this win, just
accomplished whatever.
And I wasn't getting
them from the women.
And I went out and spoke
to a number of women
and said, why aren't
you doing this?
The guys are.
And the answer was, well,
it seems really political.
And my answer is,
it's not political.
It's content.
And as a leader running
a large organization,
I won't know what you're
doing if you don't talk about.
It.
So please let me know.
Keep it pithy.
And if it's uncomfortable
to talk about yourself, say,
I want to highlight this great
thing that our team got done,
you know, my team
is extraordinary.
So you can make it about the
team, which it usually is.
So one is speaking up.
There's an expression one
of my clients once used,
which is, the absence
of information
is filled with dirt.
And I use that
expression all the time.
In fact, my kids are
tired of hearing about it,
because if they're home
after midnight, I'll say,
the absence of information
is filled with dirt,
so I assume they're obviously
dead on the side of a road,
which they aren't.
They're just out.
But it's a really
important message,
because if we don't communicate,
we don't say something,
and the guys are, they're
filling it in and we are not.
So make sure you communicate.
Don't hold back.
The second really
important one is
that when you're ready
for that next role,
I think it's really
important to say something.
And when you have a sponsor,
it makes it much easier.
What I used to do
is say, you know,
I'm kind of ready for
that next challenge.
I love to learn.
What's my highest and best use?
I'm open for anything
whenever it comes up.
It wasn't like, I need
x and I need it now.
It's what's my
highest and best use?
And the other thing I've
found with women versus men
is, I think we-- and
I will blame myself
in early days-- you
kind of say it once
and you think it's
registered, whereas men
are really repetitive.
It's like a war of attrition.
Every single week, back at
you until you respond to it.
And so what I'm telling men is,
if you hear a woman ask, think
of it as like she's
screaming from a rooftop,
and the next time
you hear, she may
be leaving the organization,
whereas men will just
do this war of attrition thing.
But what I tell women is,
increase the frequency
if you're ready for a
move, you're getting bored,
don't get to the point where
you just kind of give up
on where you are.
Ask for it.
I think that's another
really important element.
MARY GROVE: I think that's
such insightful advice for all
of us as women,
but also as women,
when we reach leadership
roles or management positions,
to keep an eye out for that.
And if we're not getting
that type of feedback
from the women on our team,
to go out and practically
seek it, and encourage
the frequent updates,
the advocating.
RUTH PORAT: Well, that's
a really important point
and it prompts another one.
And data research
supports this one, too.
Women tend to-- we
collectively tend
to think we need to
have 100% of the skills
before we're ready to say, I'm
ready for my next challenge,
whereas men need 25%
to 50% of the skills
and their hands
are up in the air.
So your point's a
really important one.
We may wait too long.
And I think even
when we're asked,
too often I find women
will say, I'm not ready.
And my response has
been, well, then, you're
telling me that I'm an idiot
because I think you are ready.
So let's have this
conversation one more time.
So even when you think
you're not ready, you are.
Think of it.
The guys only need 25% to 50%.
We're thinking we need 100%.
There's a big gulf in there.
So your point, I
completely agree with.
MARY GROVE: I know a
lot of women at Google
look at you in the most senior
level of leadership and think,
that's so inspirational.
Whether or not
I've ever met you,
had a conversation with
you, I can look up to you.
So you being in that
position of leadership,
who do you look up to?
Who are some of your main
influences and role models?
RUTH PORAT: This is not supposed
to be a political statement
because I've been answering
this question for a really
long time, well
before the election,
but-- just so you
know what I'm going.
Hillary Clinton was
my senator, and I've
been a supporter of hers
for a really long time.
And when she became
secretary of state,
she did something
that I've talked
about in a different
context that I
think is really important.
To be identified
as a great leader,
I think we each need to do
a brilliant job in our role.
And I call that our sandbox.
But then you need to go
outside of your sandbox
and really push the frontier
and take on something bigger
to actually make your
organization better
as a result.
And when she was
secretary of state,
she had her day job, which
is a pretty big day job.
And then she was also
focused on global women.
And to me, if she could
be secretary of state
and have this other
agenda, that's
exactly, in my view, what we
each need to be thinking about.
How do we do what we do and
do it really brilliantly?
And how do we make
the organization
that we're part of better as
a result of us being there?
So I would say she's the one.
MARY GROVE: She's
an impressive woman.
Absolutely.
So prior to joining Google,
you were called Wall Street's
most powerful woman.
And I'm wondering, in
moments of great adversity,
great personal challenge, how
do you maintain your power,
maintain your strength?
RUTH PORAT: Well, I
think times of adversity
are the greatest times to
learn, and to mobilize,
and to pull a team
together, and to have a win.
And they're the most
poignant parts of my career.
So I had the opportunity,
during the financial crisis,
the secretary of the
treasury at the time,
Hank Paulson, asked if I would
help lead a team to advise them
what to do with the housing
market, Fannie Mae and Freddie
Mac, a small $5
trillion industry.
And then from
there we went right
into the Lehman crisis weekend
and then the AIG weekend.
AIG was the scariest
moment throughout
the financial crisis.
It was terrifying.
And the reason it
was terrifying--
and I am getting
to your question--
the reason it was
terrifying is it
felt like individuals and small
businesses would be wiped out
and they never saw it coming.
And I was sitting there
feeling like we really
were in the midst
of what was going
to be a horrendous meltdown.
And so many people would suffer.
It was the most
frightening moment.
And beyond the, how
do you mobilize a team
to problem solve,
which gets you focused,
the other thing that
was really important
is, I was thinking of my family,
and thinking, wow, everything's
going to get wiped out.
And I thought, you know what?
We have our health I have
three amazing children.
Been married for a
really long time.
I don't have any regrets
about anything I've done.
And I think that
question-- and I've
framed it that way in the
past-- is don't have regrets.
Don't put off your
life for another day.
Don't put off for
this time when things
are going to be fine, because
you just don't know what's
going to happen along the way.
So I think problem
solving is one part of it.
And I actually think you learn
so much in times of adversity.
And don't forget to think
about how much you're
learning and getting stronger.
And then make sure,
though, that you've
done everything in your life
that you want so that you don't
question, well, why did I wait?
MARY GROVE: Absolutely.
So you talked about navigating
the financial crisis.
Now your purview is looking
after the finances of Alphabet.
No small task.
So can you share with us a
couple, maybe, life hacks
for how you personally
prioritize your time
and how you manage
your schedule?
RUTH PORAT: That's
been a journey.
I can tell you I have tried
a lot of different things.
But there are two.
First, I think
women-- at least I'll
say for myself-- really
bad at saying no.
And one of my--I actually have
it on my to do list-- say no.
Because there are
a lot of really
cool things that we get to do.
And it's really easy,
and I love to learn.
So it's like, well, I'll
do that and I'll do that.
And then all of
a sudden you find
you really don't have enough
time to live your life.
And so that's one thing,
is having the discipline
to make sure the bar
is high enough so
that when you're doing something
you're not overextended.
And I have found that to
be a learning experience.
And the other is, start each
year with a set of priorities.
For me, it's kind of, what are
the five things that are really
important to get
accomplished where
I can make a real
difference here at Alphabet?
And keep them.
They're on my to-do list.
So I have a to-do list.
It's got everybody I deal
with and the key things
I need to talk to them about.
And I go through that every day,
and it's this constant process,
so if I'm talking to you,
I'll pull out the things
that we had dealt with before.
But also on that are my
work priorities for the year
and my family
priorities for the year.
And I always look
back at those as well.
And it keeps you
kind of grounded
so that you don't end up getting
overextended, at least for me.
MARY GROVE: All on
the same list, though,
work and family together.
So it's not this notion of
a work-life bifurcation,
so to speak.
RUTH PORAT: Well, my
first time I did it,
I had the work stuff on the
left and the family stuff
on the right.
And it's sort of
evolved over time.
But it's one integrated thing.
MARY GROVE: So if you only
get to pick five things,
how high level is each bucket?
RUTH PORAT: They're
pretty high level.
MARY GROVE: It's a lot.
RUTH PORAT: There's a lot there.
MARY GROVE: Absolutely.
So I want to shift
gears a bit and talk
a little bit about the
economic environment right now.
As we've seen, we have a lot
of entrepreneurs in the room.
So I want to ask you, do you
think that current startup
valuations-- especially
here in Silicon Valley,
there's been so much talk
and so much hype-- do
you think that they
are A, reasonable,
and are they sustainable?
RUTH PORAT: If you go back over
the history of startups, what
you'll find-- and Mary
Meeker was the research
analyst at Morgan Stanley when
I was running tech banking back
in the '90s, and she used to
always make this point-- is
something like 70% fail.
70% of startups fail.
90% of the value is created
by 10% of the companies.
There's a really
high bar for success.
It is hard.
And I think the key lesson
I learned back in the '90s,
in that bubble, was that a
lot of companies were started.
But there really wasn't
anything that was truly
differentiating about them.
At the time, it was the
early days of the internet,
and people thought that if
you're using the internet,
you're an internet company.
But if you weren't doing
anything transformative,
the internet, as we
subsequently learned,
was like you launched a catalog.
There was really nothing new
and differentiating about it.
And the key thing that I spent
a lot of time on as a banker,
is this a company or
is this a product?
And so I think for
great companies,
you're going to find there'll
be a lot of interest,
and valuation can be
sustainable, in particular
given how much larger the
market is today than it was.
But you have to go back
to, in an environment where
a lot of things can get
funded, do you actually
have something
that's sustainable?
And there are times where
there's a blurring of that.
But the great companies
will transcend
whatever these kind of peaks
and valleys are in markets.
MARY GROVE: So what
are the primary lessons
that we should all remember
from the bubble of 2000?
And do you think we're
in a bubble today?
RUTH PORAT: So the main
one from the bubble of 2000
is that, do you have something
that is truly differentiated?
Is it a product?
Is it a company?
What makes it so differentiated?
And make sure you're
getting-- make
sure you've got good people
around you who can provide
some lateral vision,
who can give you
the benefit of a
lot of the scars
they've gotten going through a
whole host of experience, who
will truly challenge you.
I have often said, I like
people who are in my face,
because none of us have a
monopoly on great ideas.
And if somebody is
not challenging me,
I'm not going to get
pushed as far as I would
want if you want to succeed.
So that's probably the
most important from 2000.
There are a couple
that are really
important from the crisis of
2008, the financial crisis.
And I quote those
all the time as well.
The first and
really important one
is how important it is to
build a solid foundation
for your company well
ahead of when you need it.
Any great company, I
believe, in any industry
will fail if you don't do that.
And the metaphor
is, you would not
drive a car at 100 miles an
hour with mud on the windshield
because you can't see
where you're going.
And if you haven't built a good
foundation for your company,
you don't know when you're
about to hit a wall.
And you really need to
invest in boring stuff
like financial control
systems, risk management,
those kinds of things
that give you visibility.
That's one really
important lesson.
And the other very
important lesson
from the financial
crisis is something
Hank Paulson said
to me, which was,
you need to have the will and
the means to solve a problem.
And too often, by the
time you have the will,
you no longer have the means.
And he was talking about Greece.
There was no will to solve
Greece in the early days.
We had the financial
means to do it,
but we didn't have
the will to do it.
And as a result, it spread to
Italy and Spain and Portugal.
It became a contagion
across southern Europe.
And his point, you have to
have the will and the means,
why is that relevant
to your question?
I think it is relevant because--
and it goes back to my answer
to your first
question-- we at Google,
at Alphabet, have $73 billion.
We can do a whole
host of things.
But if we don't
prioritize, we're
going to spend a lot
of resources on things
down on the bottom of the list.
We're going to dissipate
the means, as opposed
to putting all of our weight
behind the big things.
And so prioritization, for all
of us, is really important.
And I would say when you
don't have the means,
it becomes even more important.
So I think that there
are some lessons
from the financial
crisis that actually
may be at least as relevant as
from that early tech bubble.
MARY GROVE: Think about
longevity, staying power,
prioritization-- I'm a work
in progress there for sure.
So in a few minutes I'm going to
switch over and take questions
from the audience.
And I think we have
some microphone runners.
If you have a question,
please get that ready.
But I want to ask
you a few fun ones.
So I'd love to know
what book you're
reading right now, and maybe
what's one book that you would
recommend to us?
RUTH PORAT: Well, so one
that I am-- right now
I'm sort of still drowning
in everything Alphabet.
So I have a very good intention
and a book on my bedside.
I got to see the
play "Hamilton" when
I was in New York,
which is beyond amazing.
It was absolutely extraordinary.
So I'm now trying to
get through the book.
So that would be the one that's
sitting there challenging me
all the time.
The one that I
thought was amazing,
in terms of what
would I recommend,
I thought "Half the Sky."
I think you read "Half the Sky."
MARY GROVE: I read it, yep.
RUTH PORAT: Yeah.
I mean, it's hard
to get through,
but I thought it's one of
those ones where it really
underscores how much
still needs to be done.
MARY GROVE: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
RUTH PORAT: How would
you answer that question?
MARY GROVE: So
currently I'm reading--
so Steve Case is about
to release a book called
"The Third Wave" about the
next cycle of entrepreneurship.
So I'm reading the
pre-release copy right now.
RUTH PORAT: That's fun.
MARY GROVE: One book that I
would recommend in terms of-- I
really like to read fiction
for pleasure when I can--
"In the Shadow of the Banyan."
It's a beautiful-- first-time
author, a brilliant book
about her own personal struggle
in Cambodia during the Khmer
Rouge.
But it's a goal to
read more this year.
RUTH PORAT: Exactly.
MARY GROVE: So what is next
on your travel bucket list?
RUTH PORAT: So I had the
coolest trip this Christmas.
We went to Cuba.
And next up is, if we can--
don't know if it's possible--
get to Iran.
One of the things-- I have
three boys who are amazing--
and one of the things
I've done with them
throughout their life,
starting from when they were
able to actually play
this game, is every year
we would have everyone
in the family list
what countries
you want to go to,
and then everyone got a vote.
And then we would
tally up the votes
and we would go somewhere.
MARY GROVE: Very democratic.
RUTH PORAT: It was
very democratic.
But I think that giving
them an appreciation
for the rest of the
world, and the fact
that we're just a small part
of it, was really important,
and it's been a fun game we've
played for a really long time.
MARY GROVE: So will they be
coming to Tehran with you?
RUTH PORAT: If we get to go.
They loved Cuba.
That was a good one.
If you haven't been,
I would go soon.
MARY GROVE: It's
on my bucket list.
So what are three sites
that you visit first thing
every morning?
RUTH PORAT: So I have a--
I think it's a good habit.
Some may say it's a
slightly odd habit.
Before I get out of
bed in the morning,
I make sure I get through news.
So beyond my great
Google News search,
which gives me every
category I want,
I'll read "The New York Times"
morning blast and Politico.
And because I grew up on Wall
Street, "The Financial Times."
MARY GROVE: Is that your
favorite finance publication?
RUTH PORAT: Yes.
MARY GROVE: Last question
from me, for now.
What are three apps that
you can't live without?
RUTH PORAT: Well,
everything Google,
across the board,
which is actually true.
MARY GROVE: I feel like
I'm cheating on that one.
RUTH PORAT: I know.
That's probably the bulk of it.
And then I would say
I live a lot on Uber.
MARY GROVE: Great.
So I'd love to turn it over
to our audience for questions.
You can raise your hand if
you have a question for Ruth.
Here in the corner?
Green microphone.
AUDIENCE: I was
really curious if you
could talk a little bit
more about the difference
between a company and a product,
and maybe give some examples
or features of both.
RUTH PORAT: Great question.
So without naming
names, there were
a number of large
companies in the '90s who
felt that if they took their
dot-com business public-- think
of any of the consumer
products goods companies--
they took their dot-com
business public,
it would go for some
super high valuation.
And my point-- that's
a simple example of,
that's just a
distribution channel no
different than a catalog.
So what are you doing that's
actually transformative?
Amazon did something
that was fundamentally
transformative in the
experience that you had.
They weren't doing much
that was differentiated.
eBay did something,
created a whole new market.
Priceline created
a whole new market,
a whole new way of thinking
about how you could consume,
acquire.
So for example, I
took Priceline public.
And what was fascinating
to me was it started
as just this narrow vertical.
But they could connect
the dots to the future.
What more could you do once
you've kind of gone down
this path?
And that's probably
one part of it.
The other is, if the problem
you're solving is too small,
so it's a nice feature, it's a
nice add-on to an experience,
the question is, how big
does it really scale?
So when you start by saying,
what's the total addressable
market?
How big could this really be?
If it's too narrow, then you
end up saying, that's cool.
That's a nice, cool company.
But fundamentally, it
would have more reach
if it plugged into
something broader.
So it just solves a
slice of a problem.
MARY GROVE: Yellow microphone.
AUDIENCE: So my
name is [? Snow ?]
and I'm an Android developer
at Groupon right now.
I have two questions for you.
The first, you said you
have a list of priorities
for both your work and family.
Could you share with us, at
least, maybe top one of each?
And the second thing is,
you have a really busy life
at work, right?
Like how do you manage to kind
of balance your personal life?
Like how do you find
your love of life,
and then how do you manage your
family time, things like that?
RUTH PORAT: I'm glad you
asked that because the word
balance, I think, is one
thing I would love everyone
in this room to get rid of.
Banish from your vocabulary.
I think the term balance,
which is often used,
is a trap, because we
can never be balanced.
I think-- my view is
that too often-- I'll
say for myself-- I feel
guilty all the time
that I'm not doing
enough for my family,
or I'm not doing
enough for work.
And I think women often do feel
very guilty, get that sense of,
I should be doing more here.
Men don't do it as much.
Men do a great job of just kind
of compartmentalizing things.
And there are a lot of
lessons that come from that.
But sticking with your question,
I don't view it as balance.
I view it as mix.
My view is that at
different times in life,
you're kind of more
one or more the other.
And the metaphor--
I like to think
in metaphors-- but the metaphor
for me is a kaleidoscope.
If the kaleidoscope had
half yellow and half blue,
it would be pretty boring.
If it had all yellow and all
blue, it would be even worse.
But even if it was
just perfectly equal,
nicely balanced.
Instead, it's a lot
of different colors.
And as you move throughout
life, it changes,
and that's what makes
it really beautiful.
And I was really fortunate.
My mom worked when I was
growing up and always
gave me the message
that I should work.
And I love my mom
immensely, and I'm
really close to my siblings.
So it never occurred to me that
you couldn't be a great mom
and have a great career.
And my dad was
completely gender blind
and did math problems
and soldering circuitry
and really cool stuff with me.
So I was never
told anything other
than go forth and be
what you want to be.
And when I was little,
my kids-- it was hard.
I mean, there's no question,
when you're going to work,
you have those bad days.
I was reminiscing about my
middle kid when he was little.
They're now all in their 20s.
But when he was
little, one day he
said, mommy, why do you work?
And I thought, what a great
time for a learning moment.
I work because I
love to help clients
and I love to solve
their problems.
And I work with
really fun people.
And he reflected
on it and he said,
so mommy, it comes down
to that one word, love.
Who do you love more?
Which was clearly
not the response
that I was looking for.
But if you fast
forward to when we
were going through the
financial crisis, they got it.
They knew that I was in the
middle of something that
was really important.
They were so there and they were
proud, and they really got it.
And we're super close.
And I think that
my husband and I
have launched three boys,
three, I guess, young men now
who have really good values.
They get it.
They see how wonderful
it is to have all of us
be who we can be.
So for me, this term balance--
the reason I jumped on it,
I'm glad you used it-- is
because I think it's a trap.
Think about mix, and
it adjusts over time.
And one of the very
important things
I think, as leaders,
we should all do,
is help women deal
with that guilt,
because-- what I have
set up in my prior role,
and I certainly have it
here-- is I tell women,
you know what, if there's
something you want to do,
like whatever with the family,
a kid's birthday, a parent
teacher conference, a sporting
event, whatever, don't tell me.
Just go do it,
because I trust you.
You're on my team
Don't check in with me.
Women tend to check
in more often.
Men just go do what
they need to do.
And so what I've told men is
you need to let everyone know,
don't check in with me.
Go do what you need
to do, and view it
as an investment in your
longevity at Alphabet,
at Morgan Stanley, at
wherever you happen to work.
And over the years I've had
women send me a note saying,
I know I wasn't supposed
to check in with my boss,
but I've never done that so
I'm sending you an email just
to tell you that's really cool
advice but it's still hard.
And I love it.
I mean, it's like,
yeah, bring it on.
It's fine.
Because it does feel a bit
odd if you're not there
or you're cutting
out in the afternoon.
But the guys do it.
So feel good about
it, and view it
as an investment in the
longevity of your time
at wherever it is
you're working.
I think it's really important.
MARY GROVE: Thank you, Ruth.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
My name is [? Mina ?]
[? Kasi. ?] And
I'm at the point of my career
where I'm transitioning from
an individual contributor
to management role.
So along that path, as you
said, you had several sponsors.
But at the same time, I'm
being viewed as a threat
to other colleagues
competing for the same.
Because you have gone
up the ladder so much
and you always had
sponsors, how did you
deal with any oppositions?
Or what was your way
around that problem?
RUTH PORAT: Well, I think when
you're picked versus a guy,
or when two guys are up for
a role, and one gets picked
and the other doesn't,
there's obviously
disappointment and envy
and a whole host of things.
I think that all we can do is
conduct ourselves as ethically
and responsibly as possible.
I can't deal with their problem.
Like you know what?
If you're the one who should
get picked for the role,
do it in a high-quality way.
Make sure you're super
inclusive of your team.
I think one of the
great things in leaders
is, when you're a leader, one,
over-communicate with the team.
Make sure they know
what your vision is.
And when you're in a room, make
sure you get everybody's views
before you opine on yours.
If you've got the support of
your team, those snipers who
wish they had the role
but didn't get it,
they're not going to get much
support for it because you're
going to be doing a great job.
So there have been
times in my career--
I came from an industry where
there were even fewer women.
It was tougher in
those earlier years
than, I would say,
in this industry.
And fortunately all of these
industries are changing.
There were times when I tried
to even use to my advantage,
well, you know, I'm a woman,
so they wanted a woman.
I'm not sure that's
the best answer,
and I certainly am not
going to say I advocate.
In fact, I'm even
sorry I brought it up.
But you know what?
We can't deal with
the guys' problems.
And we're just going
to move forward.
MARY GROVE: Yes, question
in the green microphone.
AUDIENCE: Hey, my name is
[? Rosha. ?] I work at Udacity.
Hey.
So my question is, what
personality traits and skills
you look for in a person
that would get you to say,
I want to sponsor that
person, and I want
to contribute to their success?
MARY GROVE: [? Rosha ?] is
an amazing entrepreneur.
We first met in Palestine,
and she lives here now.
RUTH PORAT: Oh, cool.
It kind of goes
back to my comments.
I want someone who
is challenging,
who's in my face with ideas.
One of my favorite analysts
who worked for me-- actually,
he's now here, came
here years before I did.
Very wise guy, clearly.
But you know, what
I really liked was,
he was a very young kid
right out of college
and I was a managing director.
And he was constantly
peppering me with ideas,
because as I said, none of
us have a monopoly on ideas.
So I want people who give
me real operating leverage
by provoking great ideas.
And I've often used the term
"think, don't process," which
is a really crass
way of describing it,
because I don't think
any of us just process.
But if you don't complete what
you're trying to do and then go
the next level, so put yourself
in the more senior person's
position and say, what
would I do if I were there?
So this tells me a story.
What's the next step?
Try and take it the next
step or the step beyond that.
Once you're doing that, you're
providing a ton of operating
leverage to people.
So the eureka
moment for me was, I
was so grateful to my
sponsors-- and I am.
I wouldn't have had these
roles but for sponsors--
until one day I
realized, I think
that guy's getting at
least as much out of me
as I am out of
this relationship.
It's a really fair relationship.
And that's when you
realize that it's working.
So when you're
sponsoring someone,
I've got a ton of
people, and it's probably
the most gratifying
part of my role,
is people who keep
updating me from wherever
they are in life who I've worked
with over the last 20 years.
And it's because
they've got this spark
and they're trying to
push it to the next level.
And even people who come to
me-- for example, one guy,
he kept coming up with ideas.
And I said to him,
I love the way
you think but your
ideas are too small.
Think bigger.
And so you just want to
provoke people to think,
because if you can get them
to understand how big you want
to think, or which markets
you want to attack,
they may miss the mark because
they're new at doing it,
but you can redirect them.
That's what I look for.
And so it is this challenge.
I want people who
are challenging.
MARY GROVE: We have time for
one final audience question
in the purple microphone.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to get
your opinion of, or ideas,
on that if you are somebody
who's working full-time
as a software developer,
how do you transition?
How do you plan from
working from someone
to having something of your
own, your own software service,
given the assumptions
that you have
to plan all the
financial aspect of it,
or you don't have a network.
You can take the knowledge
of a guy in a garage,
but we don't see a lot of
women in the garage creating
something.
So what's your thoughts on it?
RUTH PORAT: Well, you may have,
given your role, a lot more
to add on this than I do.
I mean, I keep coming
back to the same playbook
in certain respects,
which is, you
do need to be able
to address what's
the technical model, what's
the business model, what's
the financial model,
what's the marketing model?
Just one piece of the
puzzle doesn't solve it.
So whether you bring in
people who can do it,
I think life is a team sport.
And I want to make sure that
I'm surrounded with people who
are part of that team sport.
And so I would make sure to
fill in what those gaps are.
And there's a pretty
big network of people,
in particular, I
think, who want to see
more women thriving and
rising up and really winning.
And that's a great place to be.
MARY GROVE: I would say test.
Test the concept early
and often, right?
Put your ideas out there
with trusted people
across different disciplines,
whether it's product, design,
engineering, the business side.
There are amazing forums
like startup weekends,
these small boot camps where
you can go and actually
work on it in a mock scenario,
get real life feedback.
And the third thing
is, maybe talk
with some potential angel
investors, friends and family,
folks who have seen a lot
of these different types
of pitches come through.
And they may have a
lot of great feedback
early on before you end
up taking that leap.
RUTH PORAT: I just want
to say it's fabulous being
with all of you.
What you're doing is great.
We need to see more
women continuing
to thrive in this industry.
And it's a thrill and pleasure
to be with all of you.
So congratulations
to all of you.
MARY GROVE: And on
that note, Ruth,
I want to ask you a
couple-- if I may.
RUTH PORAT: Oh.
MARY GROVE: I like to close.
RUTH PORAT: I thought we
had one last question.
MARY GROVE: Well, I get to
sneak a couple in there.
So I wanted to ask you
to do a small game I
have called Fill in the Blank.
So I'm just going to give you--
RUTH PORAT: Mad Libs.
We're doing Mad Libs.
MARY GROVE: Brief statement.
Give me the first word or
phrase that comes to mind.
RUTH PORAT: OK.
MARY GROVE: So if I
started the company today,
it would be focused on--
RUTH PORAT: So can
I violate the rule?
MARY GROVE: Don't ask
for permission, right?
RUTH PORAT: Oh yeah, exactly.
My mom was an entrepreneur.
And I have so much
respect for entrepreneurs.
And I think people
who are entrepreneurs
should go off, and
break down those walls,
and build these great
ideas, and bring
in whatever you need to do it.
I love my role,
and I'm not going
to go be another role
because I love what I do.
And I feel like the
opportunity to be
a part of this great
company, making
sure we've got that
great foundation,
making sure that mud
is off the windshield,
solving whatever capital
structure, business capital
allocation, I love
that part of it.
And I love the fact
that I work with people
who are amazing engineers
and entrepreneurs.
And I think the most
important thing is
to be super true to yourself.
And so that's my one-word
answer to your question.
MARY GROVE: So
leadership to me means--
RUTH PORAT: Leadership means
courage, because by the time
it gets to your office,
it's not an easy--
you never get the easy things.
But you better make a
decision, because there's
nothing worse than things
just sort of dragging on.
It means being really inclusive.
As I said, I think pulling
the best ideas out,
that's what great leaders do.
And it's knowing
where you're going
with clarity, which often comes
from that process of pulling
things out.
MARY GROVE: My final one is,
my hope for the next generation
of female leaders is--
RUTH PORAT: Everything
that we all want it to be.
I think that the pendulum
has moved a lot from when
my mom was working.
And it's certainly moved
a lot from when I started.
And there's such a
great network of women
that want to see all of
you, and the next generation
coming up, not asking
these questions about,
what does it mean
as a woman versus--
just that it's so natural and
seamless and everything else.
And until that time,
we're all locked in arms,
I think, in a really
important way.
So I want huge
success, and I want
us to be running the
world because we're
better at it than anyone else.
How's that?
MARY GROVE: Thank you
very much, Ruth Porat.
[APPLAUSE]
RUTH PORAT: Thank you.